[Music]
what's going on guys so I've already
covered all the new releases that are
out this weekend I don't have any new
reviews to do until next weekend so I
thought now would be the perfect time to
do a video that I've been requested to
do for quite some time and that is an
updated tour of my background my toys my
posters all of my nerdy things and in
reality I'm just I'm looking for an
excuse to talk about toys because I'm 12
apparently also I thought it'd be a
really cool way to bring something new
into my channel and that is I've
recently gotten a subscription to loot
crate loot crate is a subscription
service that sends a box of nerdy
awesomeness to your house once a month
and I thought hey it'd be kind of cool
if once a month I showed you guys some
of the cool stuff I got and I will do
that after I show off my incredibly
awesome background that I love and that
I have crafted with years and years of
pent up childhood nostalgia and now I'm
adult and let's just look at toys
Captain Kirk what nerd collection would
be complete without him this is an
Incredible Hulk piggy bank actually but
I mean it's just a bust to me this is an
awesome battle damage Super Saiyan Goku
here's my matrix toys I have a neo vs.
Smith and I love the expression on
Smith's face it actually looks very
realistic as well as this very very
awesome pose of neo from the lobby fight
sequence of the first matrix now over to
the left here I have the one and only
solid snake this guy is the ultimate
badass in video games
and over to the left of him I have the
t1000 with some bullet holes and he also
comes with this addition which I don't
really put on because it takes up a ton
of space but it looks amazing here's my
Frieza and Goku these are two of my
favorite figures I absolutely love the
detail on both of them
I love the craft of these toys I loved
the way they were painted the colors it
all looks very realistic I also love the
way that did go whose hair along with
the power surge electricity around him
and of course what collection would be
complete without the Dark Knight himself
and it looks like I forgot to dust him
whoopsies
going up I absolutely adored the show
hey Arnold this is Arnold and his pig
Abner and this is my first Tomb Raider
toy it's sort of like a doll but it's
not a doll it's Angelina Jolie from the
film Tomb Raider is another Angelina
Jolie Tomb Raider as well as two other
generations of tomb raiders the original
and the newest and my favorite now of
course you have to have the greatest toy
of all time Buzz Lightyear this is the
crown jewel of my toy collection an
eighteen-inch arnold schwarzenegger from
predator I stare at this thing sometimes
I touch it Sabrina don't just stare at
it eat it American Psycho Christian Bale
I freaked out when I saw that thing
available Han Solo's just chillin listen
to some tunes and Jabba's palace this is
ma Jin Vegeta I love the fact that I was
able to find that toy Tetsuo
from Akira Luke with a lightsaber from
Bespin and this is my favorite Batman
toy from Batman Arkham origins as well
as Catwoman from Arkham City and that's
Christian Bale as Bruce Wayne and his
training gear from Batman Begins now I'm
not a huge fan of Dragon Ball GT but I
do love the way these figures look Super
Saiyan for Goku and Vegeta so I picked
them up this is one of my favorites as
well as xenomorph alien in all of its
glory and if you're gonna have an alien
you have to have a predator of course
there's my Samus and Link figurines both
from Pig but here's my amiibo collection
I'm not gonna be one of those guys that
collects them all because some of them
are so rare already like Wii Fit trainer
and all of these crazy priced items I
don't care I bought all these at a store
I'm not gonna spend absurd amounts of
money on things I don't need you could
say that I'm already doing that but
whatever ash from Evil Dead I got this
thing for two dollars can you believe
that and have another Dutch figure this
is a smaller and considerably less
expensive one as well as a link from
winwaker a plush now this is my most
motivational toy i have j jonah Jameson
from spider-man
this guy points at me he tells me not to
be lazy and he tells me he'll send me a
nice box of Christmas meat I have
Michael Myers and Loomis
as well as some more Dragon Ball Z toys
that guard my DBZ manga and Scully and
Mulder from the x-files as they examine
nasty ratty alien body John McClane from
the original die hard as well as
Princess Leia from Empire Strikes Back
now if you wanted a better look at my
posters instead of the kind of blurry
look you get in all my videos because
it's behind me I thought I would provide
that for you guys now now I get a lot of
questions where do I get these almost
every single one of them is the internet
guys Amazon eBay every once in a while
I'll find one in a movie theater or
somebody will give one to me but it's
almost entirely Amazon or Ebay this is
the outrider
- renders ship from shadows of the
Empire and here's a few Star Wars wood
posters I have for the original trilogy
Star Wars Empire Strikes Back and Return
of the Jedi an Indiana Jones and the
Temple of Doom Australian poster print
as well as a wall scroll for Hayao
Miyazaki's My Neighbor Totoro and a
framed poster of Dragon Ball Z battle of
gods I might like DBZ it's entirely
possible so yeah those are some of the
cool things in my background you may
have noticed I didn't show you my anime
blu-rays or all of my blu-rays or my n64
collection and that is because once a
year I do a blu-ray update video where I
show you literally everything I own it
takes forever I want to die and I will
do that again later this year a
full-fledged gigantic every blu-ray I
own video as well as an anime blu-ray
collection video the reason I'm holding
off on that is because I'm trying to
build it a little more I want it to be a
little more substantial before I make a
dedicated video to it but let's talk
about loot crate now this is pretty cool
because not only am I gonna show you the
cool stuff I got but I actually have a
really cool offer for you guys because I
like to give you guys stuff and I
because you guys have given me so much
and that's the honest truth
I really actually do look for really
cool things that I can give back to you
guys because you guys have given me more
than I ever asked for and I really
appreciate the fact that you guys watch
my videos and that's all I have to say
about that enough mushy stuff let's look
at some nerdy ass so inside my loot
crate box we have it's a space invaders
tie hi honey it's our one-year
anniversary look I have a
Oh game tie on what's that do you want a
divorce okay it's sorry ah
Voltron of Voltron t-shirt okay this is
definitely gonna be worn by me in future
videos that's for sure you guys saw my
review for Fifty Shades of Grey
this is a considerably more fun thing to
unbox than my Fifty Shades of Grey prize
pack trust me this is awesome 8-bit
sunglasses pretty cool pin with a
cassette tape on it that says rewind
maybe I should wear that whenever I do a
retro rewind video that would be pretty
cool looks like we have a little
Nintendo NES figurine all as awesome a
notebook made to look like a miniature
comic book and last what is that oh okay
this is awesome
this is definitely the crown jewel this
is yes to resist
Tom this is that did I say that right
anyway this is awesome Star Wars issue
number one and it's a variant cover only
available through loot crate this will
definitely be read by me can't wait so
yeah guys as mentioned I do like to give
stuff back to you guys and loot crate
specifically asked me if I would want to
do this for once a month and I would and
if you would like to get loot crate once
a month like I am you can go to loot
crate dot-com slash stuckman use the
coupon code stuckman that's to ends at
the end of my name and you can get a
discount on getting this once a month so
if you're interested in getting that the
cutoff date for the next box is February
19th the one that I showed off was
January's I can't wait to see the next
one I'll do this once a month for you
guys I think it's something very cool
for me because I can show off some
really awesome nerdy stuff and you guys
can get it at a discounted rate if you'd
like to go to loot crate comm slash
stuckman and use the coupon code
stuckman that's my gift to you guys I
know a lot of my subscribers have asked
me about loot crate in the past and
hopefully you guys can have as much fun
as I am having with it thank you so much
as always for watching guys I'm really
looking forward to bringing you some
really cool videos coming up very soon
including a Batman and Robin hilarious
'ti review with the one and only flick
pick teaming up with me I can't wait to
do that for you guys and of course we'll
have Hot Tub Time Machine and McFarland
USA reviews this weekend guys thank you
so much as always for watching and I
hope you have
great day as always if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]